.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Viele fragten, ob ich sicher sei.
"Du willst nicht Ulayayi heissen.
Albertin ist viel schöner."
Nicht schöner, aber vielleicht
einfacher auszusprechen.
Die Philippinen und die Schweiz
sind sehr unterschiedlich.
Geduld ist bei uns wichtig.
Er braucht mehr Geduld.
Das hast du jetzt schön gesagt.
Wir haben nicht speziell über
die Erziehung des Kindes gesprochen.
Ich denke, Romain wird der sein,
der Noam etwas mehr
mit Süssigkeiten etc. verwöhnt.
Das gibt es bei mir nicht.
Er wird
nichts Unmögliches verlangen.
Noam muss nicht mit einem Flickflack
die Treppe runterkommen.
* Romantische Ballade *
Zwei Länder, eine Liebe -
das ist "Hin und weg".
* Erwartungsvolle Musik *
Aufregung in der Tambobo Bay
auf den Philippinen.
Familie Kunz geht auf grosse Reise.
Rexiboy, schön hierbleiben.
Nicht weggehen.
Bye-bye. Bye-bye.
Es geht Richtung Hafen.
1 Std. dauert die Fahrt von Didi,
Melisa und den beiden Töchtern.
Für die Familie
ist es eine langersehnte Reise:
Endlich wird Melisa ihre Eltern
und ihre Geschwister wiedersehen.
Go in the backside there.
- Okay.
Let's go over there. Here.
Doch der starke Seegang
macht Tochter Zara zu schaffen.
Zara, ist alles gut?
Pass auf den Wind auf,
falls du erbrechen musst.
Kannst du es halten?
- Nein, es ist okay.
Schau auf den Horizont.
Familie Kunz war während
der Coronapandemie in der Schweiz.
Erst vor ein paar Wochen
ist sie zurückgekehrt.
Melisa
sehnt sich nach ihrer Grossfamilie.
Ich bin sehr glücklich,
sie nach drei Jahren wiederzusehen.
Natürlich ist man etwas angespannt,
wenn man die ganze Familie sieht.
Das ist lustig.
Weitere 6 Std. Autofahrt
liegen vor ihnen.
Melisa ist
in einem kleinen, abgelegenen Dorf
in den Bergen aufgewachsen.
Wir gehen jetzt
zum Haus meiner Eltern.
Aber zuerst
müssen wir ein Stück zu Fuss gehen.
Here.
Wir müssen die Koffer tragen.
- Ja.
Anders ist es nicht möglich.
Geht es für dich?- Ja.
Ich weiss, du bist stark.
Aber ich kann dir helfen.
Mayari, warte auf Mama.
Ja, genau.
* Lachen *
It's heavy.
- So geht es besser.
Wir sind mitten im Dschungel.
Oh, ich bin so nervös. Wir sind da.
Hey-ey-ey. Hey, Carla.
Nichte Carla
begrüsst sie mit einer Segnungsgeste.
Hello.
- Hi.
Hi.
* Sie sprechen Visaya. *
Habt ihr
dieses Willkommensplakat gesehen?
Go down. Go down.
- Yeah, go down.
Let them see you.
- Hoi.
Endlich kann Melisa ihre Mutter
wieder in die Arme schliessen.
Auch ihr Vater ist überwältigt.
Komm her. Hallo, Mama.
Lange her.
- Yes.
Die Eltern sprechen nur Visaya,
kein Englisch.
Vieles läuft über die Körpersprache.
Es ist fantastisch.
Unbeschreiblich,
endlich meine Eltern zu treffen,
nach so vielen Jahren.
Es sind Freudentränen.
Es ist wunderschön.
Als meine Mutter dich zum ersten Mal
sah, sagte sie, du sähest nett aus.
Mein Vater sagte,
wir hätten eine andere Kultur:
"Wir haben viele Ehefrauen.
In Europa hat man nur eine Frau."
Im Val Müstair schwelgen Stephanie
und Dennis Ulayayi in Erinnerungen.
Vor neun Jahren
kam Dennis in die Schweiz.
* Unverständlich *
Nein, ist gut. Danke.
0 °C und unter 0 °C.
- Ja.
Angefangen
hat ihre Geschichte vor elf Jahren.
Stephanie war mit Mutter Annelise
auf Afrikareise.
In der Sandy Beach Safari Lodge
in Sambia
genossen Mutter und Tochter
ihre letzten Ferientage.
Dennis war Hotelmanager.
Wir beide sahen ihn,
aber Mami nahm den Kontakt auf.
Sie redete mit ihm und ging zu ihm
ins Büro für Internet usw.
Der Kontakt entstand erst über dich.
Als Stephanie
zurück in der Schweiz war,
meldete sich Dennis
auf Facebook bei ihr.
Anfangs heimlich.
Ich wusste erst nichts davon.
Ja, also alles
muss ich dir auch nicht erzählen.
Solange es noch nicht spruchreif
ist, musst du nicht alles wissen.
Zweimal reiste Stephanie zu Dennis.
Mit Schmetterlingen im Bauch.
Ich ging mit einer rosaroten Brille
nach Sambia.
Ich liess mich voll darauf ein.
Jedes Mal,
wenn ich mich verabschieden musste,
zerschmetterte das meine Seele.
Wir wussten nicht, wann und
ob wir uns überhaupt wiedersehen.
Das war ja alles etwas ungewiss.
Acht Monate später
reiste er in die Schweiz.
Und in diesem besagten Monat
wurde ich ja auch schon schwanger.
Wegen des Novemberwetters, genau.
Das hast du gut gesagt.
* Unverständlich *
Vier Monate später heirateten
die beiden am Karibasee in Sambia.
* Applaus *
Aus Frau Albertin wurde Frau Ulayayi.
Ich habe keine Tochter verloren,
sondern einen Sohn gewonnen.
Kann ich den jetzt loslassen?
Fünf Monate später
kam Tochter Natasha auf die Welt.
Seitdem sind sie zu dritt.
Ich möchte schon
bald wieder zurück nach Europa,
um meiner Familie
etwas näher zu sein.
Das ist mir sehr wichtig.
Ich merke auch immer mehr, dass ich
gerne näher an Romains Familie wäre.
Jamal
ist in Münchenbuchsee aufgewachsen.
Mutter Gertrud und ihr Partner
freuen sich auf das erste Treffen
mit Enkelkind Noam.
Dann haben wir alles.
- (Mann) Das Bett ist im Auto.
Genau, mit Matratze.
Ich freue mich wahnsinnig,
aber bin schon nervös.
Ich freue mich einfach,
ihn zu halten.
Das Treffen findet in Bern statt.
Nimmst du das Bett und die Matratze?
Grossmutter Gertrud ist gerüstet.
Hoppla.
Ein Campingbett, eine Matratze,
ein paar Windeln, ein Leintuch,
eine Überraschung
und ein Kaffeekuchen.
Sie treffen sich bei Jamals Bruder
Harris und seinem Sohn Jaden.
Hallo.
- Tschau.
Hello.
Geht es gut?
- Ja.
Hello.
- Tschau.
Il a trop des choses
pour le regarder.
Ça va? Zeig, zeig.
- Oui, il est là.
Wo ist er?
- Er ist hier drin. Versteckt.
Oh, das Schätzeli schläft.
Er schläft wieder mal.
- Er schläft immer.
Komplett. Und wir haben fünf Koffer.
- Hoi, Schätzeli.
Tschau, Noam. Hallo.
Jö, Schnüferli.
Wachst du auf?
Oh, wann darf man ihn rausnehmen?
Ja, jetzt, wo er wach ist.
- Ja, hoi.
Nehmen wir ihn raus?
Ui. Ui. Ui.
- Oh, Spätzchen.
Willst du zu Grosi?
- Tschau, Schätzeli.
Oh, musst du weinen? Oh-oh.
Oh.
Ja, schau.
- Schätzeli.
So. Hallo.
Oh. Jetzt ist er hier.
- Ja, jetzt ist er hier.
Schnüferli.
Noam, das ist Jaden,
dein ältester Cousin.
Das ist gerade
ein sehr spezieller Moment.
Wir haben uns unglaublich gefreut,
nach Hause zu kommen,
und den kleinen Noam
seiner Familie vorzustellen.
Weil, ja, wir sind in Kanada.
Wir sind zwar happy,
aber wir sind einfach zu dritt.
Hier sind Grosi,
der Cousin, der Onkel und Nonno.
Und das war uns sehr wichtig.
Ich freue mich.
Jaden,
gib deinem Cousin das Fläschchen.
Denkst du, er trinkt?
Noam ist ein Leihmutterbaby
und bekommt spezielle Milch.
Das ist fantastisch,
die Milch ist sofort bereit.
Man muss
nur einen Schnuller aufsetzen
und wenn das Fläschchen leer ist,
entsorgt man es.
Das einzige,
woran wir nicht gedacht haben, ist,
dass es die in Europa nicht gibt.
Also haben wir sie mitgebracht,
genug für 15 Tage.
Das sind 17 kg Gepäck.
Wir hoffen, das reicht.
Ich bin sehr froh,
dass wir die ersten vier,
fünf Wochen zusammen zu Hause waren.
Da haben wir nicht gearbeitet.
Jetzt im neuen Jahr
haben wir easy angefangen.
Aber ja, man muss sich
sehr schnell reinleben.
Er ist einfach immer da
und braucht etwas,
auch wenn er ein sehr Einfacher ist
und viel schläft.
Ah, oui.
Kommst du noch mal zu Grosi? Hm?
* Niesen *
Gesundheit.
Dreimal? Gleich dreimal?
Jetzt hat er gelacht.
- Ah oui?
Er hat ... Hast du es gesehen?
Du hast Grosi angelächelt.
- Gell?
Die Einreise
in die Schweiz war problemlos.
So reisen wir jetzt.
* Lachen *
Drei Familienmitglieder, drei Pässe.
Das ist ja der Hammer.
Wir haben uns gedacht,
dass es einfacher ist,
wenn er beide unsere Namen hat.
Wir sind doch zwei Männer
und haben nicht denselben Namen.
Das war uns wichtig.
Wir wissen,
dass wir viel reisen werden.
So müssen wir nicht bei
jeder Immigration 2 Std. erklären.
Ich habe die Geburtsurkunde
zweimal ausgedruckt,
und ich habe auch einen Brief ...
Ich gehe nächste Woche
mit ihm nach Finnland,
komme aber alleine zurück.
Darum habe ich eine Authorisation
von ihm, dass ich reisen darf.
Ich habe alles fünfmal ausgedruckt
und in jedem Koffer deponiert.
Von den Grosseltern erhält Noam
ein ganz spezielles Geschenk:
ein persönliches Horoskop.
Er braucht keine Routine.
Il n'a pas besoin de la routine.
Keine Routine.
Nein. Er ist sehr kreativ.
- Mhm.
Autonom.
Perfekt.
Ein Naturbursche.
Il peut aller le faire tout seul.
Er kann alleine wandern gehen.
Er ist ja autonom.
Das sind die Herausforderungen,
die kommen.
Also, viel Natur, viel bewegen usw.
Bis jetzt klingt es so ...
... als wäre er sehr abenteuerlich
und sehr neugierig.
Er will immer alles wissen, behält
seine Gefühlswelt aber für sich.
Er zeigt sich stark gegen aussen,
auch wenn er verletzlich ist.
Jetzt muss ich das alles
noch auf Französisch übersetzten.
Als ich meine Schwiegereltern
zum ersten Mal traf,
war das auch herzlich.
Ich wollte die Mutter umarmen,
wie das in der Schweiz normal ist,
sie stiess mich aber zur Seite
und sagte: "Oh".
Das ist hier unten aber normal,
nur war ich nicht normal hier.
* Ruhige Musik *
Auf den Philippinen
stecken Melisa und ihre Familie
mitten in den Vorbereitungen
für das grosse Fest.
* Sie sprechen Visaya. *
So bin ich aufgewachsen.
Das Essen
kochen wir auf dem offenen Feuer.
Wir nennen das "schmutzige Küche".
Melisa
geniesst die Nähe mit Mutter Alfreda.
Sie ist glücklich,
aber auch ein wenig traurig.
Seit der Heirat mit Didi
leben wir halt sehr weit weg.
Wie fast überall auf der Welt
versammeln sich auch hier
die Männer am Grill.
Das gehört zu den Philippinen.
Bei jedem Fest machen sie
ein Schwein auf dem Grill.
Man sagt ja immer,
man müsse sich dem Land anpassen.
Das fällt mir relativ leicht.
Wenn ich das sehe ...
Das fasziniert mich.
Melisa ist
mit neun Geschwistern aufgewachsen.
Das einfache Leben hat sie geprägt.
Das will sie
auch ihren Töchtern vermitteln.
So bin ich aufgewachsen.
Wir gingen behutsam
mit Ressourcen um.
Wir waren zufrieden mit dem,
was wir hatten.
There's a mirror there.
Als wir anfangs
zu dritt im Dorf unterwegs waren,
hiess es schnell: "Ah, hoi, Dennis."
Er nahm schnell die Hauptrolle
in unserer Familie ein,
was ja sehr gut ist
und mich für ihn freut.
Das gab mir ein Gefühl von Heimat,
dieses "Hoi, Dennis".
So ist es auch in Sambia.
Nach seiner Ankunft aus Sambia
hat Dennis Ulayayi
schnell eine Arbeit gefunden.
Heute ist er Allrounder
bei einem KMU in Müstair.
Ah, das Feuer und das Holz sind gut.
Das kommt gut.
So.
Ich schaue,
dass alle Sachen sauber sind.
Das Material.
Dennis kennt alle hier ...
- Tschüss.
Okay, tschau.
... und alle kennen ihn.
(Mann) Hey, Dennis. Alles gut?
Auch, danke.
Stall noch.
Dann ist es gut für heute.
Ja. Das Treppenhaus auch.
Das ist auch gut so.
Tschüss, Gusti.
- Okay, tschüss.
Ist jemand zu Hause?
Hallo?
- Hoi.- Hallo.
Dennis und Steffi
sind seit neun Jahren verheiratet.
Diskussionen
über kulturelle Unterschiede
gibt es immer wieder mal.
Oh nein, gehst du selber
oder muss ich gehen?
Danke.
Wie viel Zucker hast du?
- Nur einen.
In Sambia gehorcht die Frau.
Wenn ich sage, "Ich gehe jetzt weg",
sagt sie, "Okay, bis später".
In Sambia ist klar, dass die Frau
mit den Kindern zu Hause ist
und der Mann sein Leben lebt.
Wenn er zu Hause ist, ist das gut,
und sonst nimmt die Frau das hin.
Das hat wahrscheinlich
mit der Kultur zu tun.
Weil wir mehr Gleichberechtigung
haben oder haben möchten,
müssen wir Dinge besprechen.
Und weil ich arbeite und
verschiedene Ämter übernommen habe,
bin ich eingespannt.
Entsprechend
muss man miteinander sprechen.
Das musste er erst lernen.
Eine Reise nach Sambia
ist kostspielig.
Natasha war als Zweijährige dort.
Spielerisch versucht Dennis,
ihre Erinnerungen
an seine Heimat wachzuhalten.
Es ist uns ziemlich wichtig, dass
wir sie zusammen ins Bett bringen,
wenn wir beide zu Hause sind.
Dennis' Abendgebet ist eigentlich
ein fester Bestandteil davon.
Ja. Es ist ein gutes Gefühl.
Als Kind musste ich
immer selbstständig ins Bett gehen.
Meine Eltern sagten:
"Geh jetzt schlafen."
Niemand
zeigte mir Liebe und Fürsorge.
Das fehlte mir sehr.
Das will ich besser machen.
Jeden Abend zeigen wir ihr,
dass alles gut ist,
damit sie mit dem Gefühl erwacht,
dass wir alle glücklich sind.
Das ist Geborgenheit.
Let us pray.
Our heavenly father, we thank you
for the day you gave us
and that you give Natasha
good sleep.
(Alle) Amen.
- And protect us in our sleep.
Amen.
- Amen.
So. Sleep well.
Good night. Love you.
- Good night. Love you.
Ist gut?
- Mhm.
Buna not. Schlaf gut. Tschüss.
- Buna not. Schlaf gut. Tschüss.
Stephanie ist im Gemeinderat.
Heute Abend ist Versammlung.
Du, also ...
Politisch
würde es dich schon interessieren,
aber die Sprache
ist einfach noch ein Problem.
Wenn du Romanisch kannst,
kannst du in den Gemeindevorstand,
dann trete ich zurück.
Gut.
Tschüss, Schatz.
- Tschüss.
Wir sehen uns.
- Ja, morgen.
* Ruhige Musik *
Auch Stephanies Mutter ist politisch
interessiert und mit dabei.
Stephanie ist Schulvorsteherin
und gehört keiner Partei an.
Hoi, Gabriela.
- Tschau. Hoi.
* Sie sprechen rätoromanisch. *
Ich denke, für dich ist es auch
ein Lernprozess im Gemeindevorstand.
Auf jeden Fall.
- Man kann viel fürs Leben lernen
und sieht auch die Gemeinde ...
Von einer anderen Seite.
- ... aus einem anderen Blickwinkel.
* Sie spricht rätoromanisch. *
* Erwartungsvolle Musik *
Auf den Philippinen
ist alles bereit für das grosse Fest.
Zerteilt er die Knochen?
Nein,
er schneidet die Schnüre durch.
Okay.
* Sie spricht Visaya. *
Für das mehrtägige Fest
gibt es vier gute Gründe:
der Besuch von Familie Kunz
und drei Geburtstage,
die gefeiert werden wollen.
* Sie betet. *
Amen.
(Alle) # Happy birthday to you.
# Happy birthday to you.
# Happy birthday, happy birthday,
happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Gaga.
Happy birthday, Liam.
Happy birthday.
- Ja.
Happy birthday, Zeekke.
- Yay.
Ein so reichhaltiges Buffet
ist für die Grossfamilie
ein seltenes Vergnügen.
Das Fleisch ist sehr gut.
Das war 3 Std. im Feuer.
Das ist so gut hier, aber ich
kann es nicht richtig schneiden.
Ich habe bis heute nicht gelernt,
mit dem Löffel zu schneiden.
* Emotionale Ballade aus Boxen *
Auf den Philippinen ist nur ein Fest
mit Karaoke ein richtiges Fest.
* Eine Frau singt schräg. *
Da müssen alle Gäste durch.
* Zufriedenes Lied *
# Such a feeling's comin' over me.
# There is wonder
in most everything I see.
# Is the love that I've found,
ever since you've been around.
# Your love's
put me at the top of the world.
Bravo.
Ich träume davon,
dass wir in fünf Jahren ...
... ein etwas ruhigeres Leben
führen können.- Ja.
Also, dass wir
nicht mehr so viel arbeiten müssen.
Wir sind momentan sehr engagiert.
Und dass wir
unser eigenes Haus haben.- Ja.
Der Traum wird wahr werden.
Und dass wir alles
etwas gemütlicher nehmen können.
Auf Bali sind Dewa Artawan
und seine Frau Monica
unterwegs zu ihrem Herzensprojekt.
Es ist sehr aufregend,
weil jetzt endlich der Tag kommt,
den wir uns
seit vier oder fünf Jahren wünschen.
Wir können
echt langsam Überlegungen machen,
um den Traum Wirklichkeit zu machen.
Ihr Traum
liegt mitten in der Natur auf 800 m2.
Diese Anlage
möchten die beiden übernehmen
und Massagen,
Yoga und gesundes Essen anbieten.
Monica als Managerin
und Dewa als Koch.
Es zieht mich immer rein,
so mitten in der Natur.
(Mann) Du könntest
auch noch mehr daraus machen.- Ja.
Unternehmer Ueli Wick,
gebürtiger Glarner,
und die einheimische Architektin Vera
inspizieren die 15-jährige Villa.
Wenn man da nach vorne schaut -
ich fände das sensationell
für ein Restaurant.
Jetzt hat es da noch Wolken,
aber wenn die weg sind,
hat man den Gunu Magung.
Das könnte die Restaurantküche sein.
- (Vera) Das ist die beste Lage.
Es ist für Fremde,
aber auch für Hotelgäste zugänglich.
Auch Dewa hat klare Vorstellungen.
Punkt 1 ist gesundes Essen.
Und balinesische Küche
gemischt mit indonesischer Küche.
Das ist unser Konzept.
Das haut einen einfach um, wenn man
hier ist und in die Weite sieht.
Das ist wie in einem Adlerhorst.
Du könntest eine Extension machen.
- Es friert mich schon wieder.
Das ist wirklich ein magic place.
Ueli könnte die Villa mit Luxuszelten
aus seiner Firma erweitern.
Er ist am Projekt interessiert.
Sonst hast du hier
wirklich nur Farmland.
Das ist auch eine geschützte Zone.
Daher sind wir hier
ziemlich alleine.
Das macht es
schlussendlich auch aus.
Doch Architektin Vera hat Bedenken.
Eine Herausforderung?
- Eine grosse Herausforderung.
Das Gelände des Resorts ist sehr
steil und müsste terrassiert werden.
Wow.
Ja.
Hier oben ist man König.
Dieser steile Teil
wird eine Herausforderung.
Wie schaffen wir mehr Unterkünfte?
Yes ...
Der Ausblick ist da,
die Schönheit ist da,
aber die Herausforderung
ist die Sicherung des Geländes.
Wir müssen das
mit den Behörden klären.
Die Unterkünfte wären sehr nah am
Fluss - das könnte gefährlich sein.
Wir müssen schauen,
wo wir was bauen können.
Wir brauchen mind. ein Jahr
für die Renovation der Anlage.
Und für die Konstruktion.
Wir müssen schauen,
wann wir beginnen können.
Mitten im Monsun sicher nicht.
All das müssen wir berücksichtigen.
Inzwischen ist der Traum geplatzt.
Der Staat hat das Land
zur unbebaubaren Zone erklärt.
Monica und Dewa
lassen sich nicht entmutigen.
Sie brüten bereits über neuen Ideen.
* Entspannte Musik *
Meine ideale Vorstellung wäre,
dass wir zwei mit zwei Kindern
in Nizza wohnen.
Ich sehe mich dort.
Es hat noch nicht geschneit.
Seit zwei Monaten sind Jamal
und Romain Väter des kleinen Noam.
Noch haben die beiden frei,
aber bald wird Romain wieder
als Eiskunstlaufcoach tätig sein.
Jamal will später wieder Teilzeit als
Schulleiter der Ice Academy arbeiten.
Continue ton dodo.
Wir gehen spazieren.
Jetzt ist das Wetter so schön.
Wir müssen noch etwas gehen,
denn bald wird es sehr kalt.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie oft wir dann noch gehen.
Aber du brauchst
ab und zu frische Luft.
Ich weiss.
Schützt ihn das vor der Kälte?
* Unverständlich *
Er ist nicht erwacht.
Le bonnet ... C'est parti.
C'est bon?
Ah, hopp.
So siehst du ihn nicht mehr.
Doch ich sehe ihn.
Den kleinen weissen Bären. Er gähnt.
Der Schweizer Jamal
und der Franzose Romain
sind seit zehn Jahren ein Paar.
Sie haben
einen weiten Weg hinter sich.
Bis
zur Erfüllung ihres Kinderwunsches
vergingen vier lange Jahre.
Jetzt dreht sich alles um Noam.
Er ist Kanadier.
Wir müssen ihn vorbereiten.
Er wird unsere Kultur mitbekommen,
aber er wird Kanadier sein
und ganz viel Ahornsirup trinken.
Mit ihrem Leihmutterbaby
wollen die beiden
auch anderen kinderlosen Paaren
Mut machen.
Und ihre Familienplanung
ist noch nicht abgeschlossen.
Für die Zukunft fühle ich mich schon
so glücklich, mit Jamal und Noam.
Was soll man sich
noch mehr wünschen?
Weiterhin Träume zu haben ...
Vielleicht ein kleiner Bruder
oder eine kleine Schwester für Noam.
Vielleicht.
Das ist so ein Moment, an dem man
kaum an die Zukunft denken kann.
Aber ich hoffe,
dass es zwischen uns so bleibt
und unserer neuen Familie so bleibt,
wie es jetzt ist.
Dass wir für den Rest unseres Lebens
so glücklich bleiben können.
* Zufriedene Musik *
Ich liebe dich,
weil du die Kinder unterstützt,
ihre Wünsche, ihre Ausbildung
und mich auch.
Du bist immer an meiner Seite
und unterstützt mich.
Darum liebe ich dich.
Auch Didi und Melisa
denken an die Zukunft.
In der Stadt gibt es für ihre Töchter
bessere Schulen.
Sie überlegen,
hier ein weiteres Haus zu mieten.
Hier irgendwo
in den Zwischenstrassen oder so
gibt es alte Häuser oder
ein Stück Land, das noch frei ist.
So könnten wir ein kleines Stück
haben und ein Geschäft eröffnen.
Ja.
Gehen wir mal schauen.
Wir haben mal ein Haus gesehen hier,
das zu mieten war.
Ich weiss nicht mehr -
diese Strasse oder diese.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich weiss es nicht mehr so genau.
Wir laufen mal und schauen.
- Ja, wir schauen.
Der Umzug
ist eine grosse Entscheidung,
die sie gemeinsam treffen wollen.
Das Haus in der Tambobo Bay
wollen sie behalten.
Das sieht nicht so schön aus,
das Land hier.
Aber wir
könnten sicher eine Pacht machen.
Ja.
Da ist eine Busstation
und da unten ein kleines Restaurant,
mit Sachen, Hochzeitskuchen
und allem, was dazugehört.- Ja.
Ich wünsche mir
ein kleines Restaurant.
Kochen und Essen sind wichtig.
Die Menschen essen dreimal am Tag.
Das wäre eine gute Einnahmequelle.
Die Familie lebt von Didis Rente.
Falls ihre Kinder dereinst
eine bessere Schule besuchen wollen,
wäre ein Zustupf von Melisa
willkommen.
Das wäre jetzt ein Haus,
das wir mieten können.
Die sehen halt alle
etwas heruntergekommen aus.
Aber dann setzt man sie instand,
malt sie neu an und macht,
was man machen muss.
Man mietet es so,
in diesem schlechten Zustand.
Die Miete
ist dafür auch nicht so hoch.
Die kann man gut bezahlen.
Da unten
könnte man gut einen Laden machen
und oben ist dann die Wohnung.
Es würde stimmen.
Einfach, aber günstig.
Ja.
Ich denke, dass man das
für 200 Fr. pro Monat mieten kann.
Ja.
That's nice, right? Love.
- Ich liebe dich.
* Aufgestellte Musik *
In Müstair riecht es heute Abend
ein wenig wie in Sambia.
Die Liebe zum Essen aus ihrer Heimat
verbindet
die Landsleute Lindsey und Dennis.
* Sie sprechen in ihrer Sprache. *
Mehr.
Ja. Besser mehr als wenig.
Wirklich wie zu Hause.
Wir messen die Zutaten nicht ab.
Nur nach Augenmass.
It's there.
- Ja, ja.- Ja.
Nshima ist ein typisches Gericht
aus Sambia.
Die Sauce besteht aus Zwiebeln,
Tomaten und dem Gemüse Kapenta.
You can't measure
with measuring cups. It's fun.
You wanna try?
I'll hold this for you.
Gut.
- Sehr gut.
Steffi, komm und versuch es.
- Nein.
Thank you, Natasha.
Come on, try.- No.
Eine Frau, die auch mit einem Afri-
kaner verheiratet ist, sagte mir:
"Lern nie, Nshima zu kochen,
sonst wirst du irgendwann jeden Tag
am Herd stehen und Nshima kochen."
Das nahm ich mir zu Herzen
und habe es nie gelernt.
So.
What do you think?
So, Schatz. Guten Appetit.
- I got it.
So, this one is the oven ...
Ich bin Gast hier,
wieso muss ich kochen?
* Lachen *
Das ist das einzige Haus,
wo ich Gast bin und koche.
It's a nice guesthouse, no?
- Ich komme nie mehr.
Ich bin megazufrieden. Megacool.
Ich glaube, es war vor einem Jahr,
als wir Nshima kochten.
Du kamst in die Küche und sagtest:
"Es ist,
als ob viele Leute hier wären."
Wir sind so laut.
Yes.
Da sind sich Stephanie
und Lindseys Schweizer Mann einig.
Das Essen, meine Muttersprache,
mit der ich aufgewachsen bin -
das vermisse ich.
Und das Zusammensein
mit Freunden aus Sambia.
Diese Offenheit.
Das fehlt mir manchmal.
Natasha, ist es nicht zu scharf?
In Sambia ist es normal,
dass die Frau kocht
und der Mann am Tisch sitzt.
Mit einem Bier.
- Mit einem Bier schaut er zu.
Immer am Nörgeln:
"Das Essen ist nicht gut."
Mein Vater hatte vier Ehefrauen.
Ich habe gesehen,
wie er sie behandelte.
Das gefiel mir nicht und ich dachte:
"Das ist nicht okay."
Nice.
Dennis will es besser machen.
Hier, wo er mit Steffi,
Natasha und einem ganzen Dorf
eine neue Heimat gefunden hat.
Für die Zukunft wünsche ich mir,
dass Didi gesund bleibt ...
... und für die Kinder,
dass sie eine gute Zukunft haben.
Wir versuchen das jetzt,
wo sie selbstständig werden.
Das ist sehr wichtig
für mich bzw. uns.
Als ehemaliger Bademeister
ist Didi im Wasser in seinem Element.
Die Familie teilt diese Leidenschaft.
Es sind reine Glücksmomente.
Es ist fantastisch und unglaublich,
wie Familienleben sein kann.
Mein grosses Glück
sind meine Kinder.
Sie halten mich jung.
Wir schwimmen zusammen,
gehen da und dort hin.
Wir machen immer etwas.
Auch wenn ich älter werde:
Wir haben Power
und können zusammen etwas machen.
Das ist wunderschön.
* Entspannte Musik *
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023